we asked high-pitch Eric how he was
preparing for the coronavirus I bought
juice water because it sounds worse my
protein shakes no he's a guy who weighs
close to 400 pounds you know he's not
buying fruits and healthy foods their
refrigerator is stocked with soda I just
don't understand why I asked a lie about
what he eats because he knows that you
would tell him that that's the wrong
stuff to have this is weird high pitch
Eric offered a message of hope usually
you know we turned to like Governor
Cuomo for that but nevertheless Eric has
been posting uplifting speeches on
social media really yes he did a message
of hope while sitting in his truck he's
addressing that's what we need
friends what's for the best pray for the
best and let's hold ascends he is alone
he's not alone he's not alone yes I am
I'm down here alone
Eric emails me a lot during the show so
he sent me a picture from his house and
I could see a ton of medication and what
appears to be 32 cupcakes there's 5
files a cupcake stacked above each other
well there you go yeah I mean he's
eating healthy foods he said in his yeah
keeping a lot of salads and vegetables
around
you